je me suis dis bah tiens alors on danse
/ frein je me suis dit automatiquement
j'ai envie de parler du fond pas de pop
champaign
voilà ça m'intéressait pas surtout qu'un
a déjà fait bien mieux que moi
c'est super bien écrit là mais l'ol est
incroyable l'air de rien parle à tout le
monde
c'est pas donné à tout le monde d'avoir
à se séparer de rester mais
je revois tout c'est ça qui est génial
effet un autre monde c'est penser qu'ils
nous font vivre
il ya quelques jours j'ai rencontré
stromae alors ce travail et tout le
monde le connaît mais alors comment
définir son style et expliquer son
succès et bien il m'a livré quelques
secrets en guise d'intro pour le
présenter on pourrait citer une
personnalité et un talent unique plus de
5,6 millions d'albums vendus à travers
le monde des concerts d'ailleurs dans le
monde entier et un nouvel album
multitude sortie le 4 mars après huit
ans d'absence un album qui a déjà battu
des records
alors ce combat il s'est fait connaître
notamment avec ses leçons qui accumule
aujourd'hui des millions de vues sur
youtube où il explique les secrets de
fabrication de ces musiques aujourd'hui
on va en quelque sorte prolonger tout ça
et se plonger dans l'univers de stromae
avec stromae en personne tant qu'à faire
on va pas se gêner alors j'espère que ça
va vous plaire évidemment abonnez vous
pour ne pas louper la suite et nos
autres vidéos et on est parti
[Musique]
la première chose majeurs analyse et
quand on s'intéresse au style de stromae
c'est sa musicalité en effet stromae est
connu pour mêler plein de styles
musicaux différents que ce soit des
musiques du monde du rap ou encore de
l'électro et pour bien comprendre ce qui
fait l'originalité de sa musique il faut
déjà s'intéresser à la variété des
instruments utilisés en effet il utilise
tout simplement un mix d'instruments
venant des quatre coins du monde des
instruments qu'on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude d'entendre et c'est le cas
dans son nouvel album multitude l'idée
derrière c'était vraiment de brouiller
les pistes quoi c'était de se dire bah
tiens en tant qu'auditeur j'ai envie
qu'on se demande tiens ça me fait penser
à la chine en même temps la rythmique et
les afro pop et puis ou alors ça me fait
penser à du baroque et puis en même
temps c'est de les rythmiques
brésilienne donc l'idée c'était vraiment
de brouiller les pistes et d'un an fait
finalement d'être un peu nulle part quoi
et c'est un peu genre comme si pour moi
la pop et aujourd'hui c'était de la
world music quoi finalement mon frère
aussi l'udc a fait un gros travail de
curation de recherche
chez plein d'instrumentistes de
musiciens et lors des voeux est alors
souvent ça donne pas vraiment un truc
terrible et puis et puis parfois il ya
des perles et on se dira ça c'est bon
c'est vraiment la direction qu'on veut
et voilà c'est un peu c'est toujours ce
process de recherche quoi bon le morceau
la sollicitude par exemple on retrouve
les roues qui est un instrument
traditionnel chinois une sorte de violon
à deux cordes
[Musique]
ou
encore le n'est qu'une sorte de flûte en
bois originaire de turquie qu'on
retrouve dans la musique pas vraiment
[Musique]
et on peut enfin c'était la cornemuse
dans le morceau invaincu qui arrive vers
la fin la chanson après tous les
instruments de leur caste
[Musique]
c'était une volonté de stromae dans le
but d'avoir un titre qui pourrait être
jouée par exemple pendant des grandes
compétitions sportives avec plein
d'instruments et une musicalité très
solennelle et par ailleurs au delà des
instruments à proprement parler stromae
s'inspire aussi plus largement beaucoup
de styles musicaux qui viennent du monde
entier pour faire sa musique c'est une
envie personnelle parce que j'aime
mélanger les cultures et tous et puis
c'est un peu comme ça que j'ai grandi la
démarche est que moi j'essaye un peu
vulgairement avec mes connaissances de
la musique du monde même si ce terme
veut rien strictement rien dire ça en
dépendent ça dépend du point de vue de
la route est évidemment mais donc moi
j'ai fait avec ce que je connaissais
j'ai fait des recherches par exemple
dans l'est dans les coeurs bulgare parce
que au début d'un trop de ghost in the
shell et a secure bulgare qui je pense
est moins en fait été japonais tu vois
mais en fait je creuse et je me rends
compte que ces bulgares bref et c'est la
même chose pour tous les instruments et
même s'il n'a pas une influence précise
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs du coup la
richesse et l'originalité de sa musique
stromae admet tout de même qu'il existe
une sorte de dénominateur commun dans
son approche de la musique et c'est en
l'occurrence l'amérique latine j'imagine
qu'un mégot 1 mais après ils évoluent tu
vois ouais mais je dirais que déjà déjà
les mélodies latines ça c'est un truc de
base qui moi me touche de toujours quoi
donc forcément moins sûr mais surtout
mes albums y aura toujours au moins une
ou deux mélodies latines quoi autres
influences qu'on peut évoquer pour
parler du style de stromae c'est aussi
le rap puisque c'est avec le rap au
début des années 2000 qu'il a commencé à
s'intéresser à la musique
[Musique]
- limites au début je me dis bon bah
j'aime bien le rap donc je vais faire du
rap et puis après je commence à me
rendre compte que c'est peut-être plus
intéressant d'être d'être habillé
différemment puis c'est peut-être plus
intéressant dans les mélanges et le rap
avec d'autres styles ah et puis on voit
qu'un à doute qu'ils ont fait je pense à
kid cudi
et puis après je me dis ah ben tiens
pourquoi pas et ainsi de suite et après
finalement on se dit ah mais en fait la
différence et une force et donc et donc
c'est là que tu commences à te
singulariser quoi et j'aime bien quand
ça quand ça quand on casse les codes et
je pense que comme beaucoup de courants
musicaux
l'europe casse les codes et c'est ça qui
est super intéressant alors même si le
rappela énormément inspiré aider à se
lancer dans la musique stromae admet
tout de même qu'il ne pouvait pas se
limiter à ce genre moi je me disais mais
en fait moi je fais pas du rap je fais
de la musique et la musique ça englobe
le rap est donc c'est pour ça que je me
suis dit mais en fait moi je suis
musicien quoi donc je fais aussi du rap
mais pas ce mac pas que en fait j'ai
envie de faire plein de trucs différents
c'est ça qui m'amuse bref pour résumer
d'un point de vue de la musicalité
l'originalité de stromae tient sûrement
au mélange d'univers venant du monde
entier gala fois ça rend sa musique
difficile disons à placer dans une case
et en même temps c'est peut-être
justement ce qui fait son style
[Musique]
pour comprendre la recette stromae il
faut aussi se pencher sur l'écriture une
écriture qui jouent alors évidemment pas
tout le temps mais qui de même assez
souvent sur des contradictions en gros
musicalité très joyeuse titre à
connotation positive mes paroles bien
plus sombre c'est le cas sur alors on
danse qui évoque des problèmes du
quotidien noyer est oublié dans une
soirée vraiment très alcoolisé alors que
la musicalité invite justement à danser
et en fait naturellement j'ai je me suis
dis bah tiens alors on danse ou refrain
je me suis dit automatiquement j'ai
envie de parler du fond pas de pop shop
in
et voilà ça m'intéressait pas surtout il
y en a d'autres qui ont déjà fait bien
mieux que moi donc je me suis dit ban à
moi ce qui m'intéresse quand je suis
dans une boîte de nuit c'est de devoir
c'est un peu dur que dit comme ça mais
un peu à peu la misère humaine aussi
quoi ya pas que il n'ya pas que des
paillettes ya aussi beaucoup de beaucoup
de west c'est dur le milieu de la nuit
aussi à y est on extériorise beaucoup de
choses et tout est et voilà je vous les
citez des brefs c'est peut-être ça qui
est un peu définit la façon de faire est
bon j'ai essayé aussi d'en sortir un
petit peu rires avec bonne journée
l'instru est quand même plutôt joyeux
les textes sont plutôt joyeux donc voilà
après c'est vrai que c'est pas la
majorité de l'album mais quand même mais
qu'est ce qu'il
veut et stromae n'hésite pas non plus à
s'emparer de thèmes d'actualité qui lui
tiennent à coeur pour déclaration par
exemple c'était un peu l'actualité c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai sujet d'actualité
la le féminisme et toutes ces questions
là forcément
et c'est pour ça la raison c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai hésité à la
mettre dessus c'était tellement
d'actualité que je trouvais ça un peu ça
va quand les artistes qui hésitent à
parler du co lead
exactement surtout qu'on en sort et je
crois que c'est vraiment une mauvaise
idée d'en parler après j'en fais je fais
un clin d'oeil par dessus sur le col
vide dans bonne journée mauvaise journée
mais non ça dépend des fois c'est des
trucs qui peuvent être personnel des
fois que des trucs qui ne le sont pas je
dirais qu'en général ce tueur 20% ou 30%
de ce que je suis vraiment après comme
ma femme me dit franchement ça te
ressemble pas vraiment c'est pas toi
quoi
[Musique]
ces performances on live lors de ses
concerts sont un autre élément de ce mix
de smash up qu'on pourrait dire très
caractéristique du style stromae qu'on
voit depuis tout à l'heure ses shows
vont mêler en fait différentes
inspirations scénographique avec un
mélange de nouvelles technologies très
tape-à-l'oeil d'un côté et aussi de mise
en scène qui sont très sobres de l'autre
côté et sur sa nouvelle tournée
multitude tour par exemple il a misé sur
une scénographie à la pointe de la
technologie au début de son show un film
d'animation projeté sur écran géant
montre des images de désert un monolithe
façon 2001 odyssée de l'espace --un
stromae en avatar qui prépare sa tournée
mondiale jusqu'à 2023 on s'y est pris à
l'avancé puisque l'animation ça prend
vraiment du temps donc ça a commencé
avec des petites animations vraiment
très rush sur maya et tout ça et puis
après ça a évolué c'est de mieux en
mieux ces animations certes à illustrer
ses chansons pour donner encore plus de
poids notamment aux paroles pour sa
chanson quand c'est qui évoque le thème
du cancer l'écran géant se désarticule
en quinze plus petits panneaux sur
lesquels coulent une sorte de l'avs
argentée qui menacent stromae même
technique pour son titre l'an faire une
chanson qui parle notamment de pensées
suicidaires les écrans forme d'un mur de
nuages blancs et rouges qui sont prêts à
envelopper stromae et parfois
l'utilisation de la technologie et plus
légères comme par exemple quand un chien
robot vient apporter une serviette à
stromae ce qui donne forcément une
touche plus légères alive l'envi set
quand même diverti fin mon métier c'est
de divertir c'est comme ça que je le
définis mais un plein de manières de
divertir évidemment moi ma manière c'est
de passer par plein d'émotions et et
donc il dit passer par des émotions dit
des tableaux quoi et c'est comme ça que
moi je vois à chaque fois c'est comme ça
qu'on se construit de live en général
donc on part deux ont fait une set list
on se dit on commence par seulement sur
la truck et où on le fait mûrir et puis
une fois que c'est figé dans le marbre
là on en voit et on se dit ok ça c'est
intel qui veulent faire ça c'est intel
qui va le faire et pourtant malgré
toutes ces nouvelles technologies
stromae tient à rester dans la sobriété
et donner une impression de concert
intimiste le plus possible malgré
forcément des salles très grande stromae
est quasiment tout le temps seul sur
scène avec son micro et seuls quatre
musiciens toujours les mêmes depuis ses
débuts l'entourent il essaie de mélanger
quoi il ya le visuel et en même temps et
on essaye de ne pas trop non plus se
sentir au cinéma donc des fois il faut
que pas ne pas oublier que la tension
d'un disneyland et le site de partout et
que ça explose et machin voilà faut que
ça reste quand même humain et un toit
compliment que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
sur le live c'est que on m'avait dit que
malgré tout la technologie parce que des
bras robotisés tout ça y'a des trucs
vraiment hyper technologique et tout ça
reste humain et samassa j'ai vraiment
beaucoup apprécié parce que ça peut vite
perdre 50 et avec quand tu travailles de
la technologie et c'est donc ce
contraste est ce mélange entre modernité
et sobriété qui caractérise
véritablement l'ensemble de ses
performances
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bref entre la musique l'écriture la
réalisation le stylisme ou encore la
performance et la communication vous
l'aurez compris stromae se sert de tout
et aime énormément mélanger ou l'a vu
ses inspirations sont multiples les
thèmes sont mixées instruments sont
variés son maître mot brouiller les
pistes du coup un grand merci à lui vous
trouverez d'autres séquences de
l'interview de stromae sur le compte
instagram hugo décrypte point pop je
vous mets le lien directement en
descriptions et au passage j'en profite
pour vous dire qu'il ya quelques mois on
a sorti une vidéo avec le chanteur ed
sheeran dans laquelle il me dévoile les
secrets pour faire un hit selon lui
c'est un autre sujet mais tout aussi
passionnant si on met ça vous intéresse
et bien là aussi je vous mets le lien en
descriptions ou autrement vous tapez
hugo du crime et sheeran je pense vous
pourrez le trouver n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner évidemment pour nous soutenir et
ne pas louper les vidéos suivantes
prenez soin de vous et on se dit ah très
vite
[Musique]